ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES BELL.
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALLY.
DODD.
THEY'RE ALSO.
GALGIANI.
GLAZER GONZALEZ.
GROVE HERTZBERG HILL HUESO --
TADO.
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING.
MORLOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH.
RUBIO SKINNER STERN.
STONE.
NUMBER BY KATHY WIENER WILK.
ALL RIGHT A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BE N THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE'LL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN REVEREND
ELIZABETH BRICK.
FROM THE UNITED METHODIST CHURCH
OF RANCHO CORDOVA AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AS WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR GORGEOUS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PRAY WITH ME [inaudible]
HOLY.
ONE CREATOR OF ALL THINGS.
YOU GO BY MANY NAMES BUT ALWAYS.
WE RECOGNIZE YOU IN THE GIFT OF
LOVE.
YOUR LOVE OPENS OUR HEARTS AND
AWAKENS OUR MINDS.
YOUR LOVE CALLS US TO SELFLESS
SERVICE.
YOUR LOVE GUIDES US TO EXERCISE
COMPASSION AND CARE.
YOUR LOVE CAUSES US TO PAUSE AND
TO BE FULLY PRESENT WHERE WE ARE
AND WITH WHOM EVER YOU HAVE
PLACED BEFORE US.
YOUR LOVE INVITES US TO BE OUR
BEST SELVES AND YOU SEE THE BEST
IN OTHERS.
HOLY ONE THANK YOU FOR THE GIFT
OF MEANING FULL SERVICE IN THIS
WORLD.
THANK YOU FOR THE MANY GIFTS OF
OUR CITIZENS WHOSE LIVES AND
WELL BEING YOU HAVE ENTRUSTED US
WITH.
THANK YOU FOR OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND FOR THE FINE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
MAY WE HONOR EACH OF THESE IN
OUR ACTIONS EACH DAY.
AND MAY WE BE ABOUT YOUR WORK OF
LOVE.
BLESS ALL OF OUR PROCEEDINGS
THIS DAY AND ALWAYS.
IN YOUR NAME AND IN YOUR WAY WE
PRAY [inaudible]
A MAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE [inaudible]
A FORMER [inaudible]
ALL.
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
AND SENATOR MAGUIRE'S CAN BE
TAKING UP ITEM THIRTY EIGHT AT
THE PRO TEM'S DESK [inaudible]
OKAY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY BY
SENATOR REQUIRE RELATIVE TO
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AWARENESS DAY.
CENTER MCGUIRE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS -- I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SR.
FIFTY YES SIR FIFTY RECOGNIZES
TODAY'S POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
DISORDER.
ALSO KNOWN AS PTSD AWARENESS DAY
HERE THE GOLDEN STATE.
THROUGHOUT THE HISTORY OF THIS
GREAT COUNTRY MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS MILLIONS OF
ANSWERED THE CALL OF DUTY WITH
THE ARMED FORCES.
EVEN THOUGH THEY PUT THEIR LIFE
IN HARM'S WAY.
THE BEER TO PROTECT OUR FREEDOMS
AND DEMOCRATIC VALUES AND OUR
WAY OF LIFE.
NOW ONE OF THE KNOWLEDGE THE
MEMBERS OF THIS CHAMBER WHO ARE
WITH THIS AND FOUGHT FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
SENATOR GROVE IN ARCHULETA
ROSTER NUMBER.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED IN-THE ARMED FORCES.
AT TIMES HAVE FACED.
HORRIFIC EXPERIENCES THAN WE
KNOW.
EVEN IF YOU'RE A SOLDIER WHO
ISN'T DEPLOYED TO AN ACT OF WAR
ZONE.
PTSD IS IMPACTING AMERICAN
TROOPS WITH RECORD NUMBERS.
MISTER PRESIDENT DESPITE THE
FACT THAT LESS THAN 15% OF
AMERICAN FORCES SEE COMBAT.
THE US MILITARY NOW HAS THE
HIGHEST RATE OF PTSD IN HISTORY.
ALL OF THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT DEFENSE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
TO MAKE GREAT ADVANCES IN THE
PREVENTION DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT OF PTSD AMONG VETERANS
WE KNOW THAT SIGNIFICANT.
CHALLENGES STILL REMAIN.
MEMBERS I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY
TO BE ABLE TO ASK THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE BRAVERY OF THESE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE WITH THIS.
IN THE SENATE TODAY.
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
NATION.
AND ALSO RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
FOCUS ON EXPANDED PTSD SERVICES
FOR ACTIVE MILITARY PERSONNEL
AND VETERANS.
AND THEN WE DECLARE THE TWENTY
SEVENTH OF JUNE.
TODAY PTS PTSD AWARENESS DAY
HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER PRESIDENT.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD AND I
WOULD ASK EVERYONE FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE IN A COMBAT
SITUATION -- YOU SERVED IN THE
MILITARY -- AND YOU ARE IN A
COMBAT SITUATION OVERSEAS LIKE
MANY OF OUR MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE. TO GET YOUR YOUR
ETS YEAR YOUR EXIT ORDERS AND
YOU HAVE YOUR ORDERS AND YOU
COME BACK HOME.
AND IN JUST A FEW WEEKS TIME YOU
HAVE TO GO FROM.
LIFE AND DEATH SITUATIONS WHERE
YOU WATCH THINGS HAPPEN THAT ARE
JUST UNMENTIONABLE TO NORMAL
ACTIVITY IN GOING TO THE GROCERY
STORE.
AND THAT IS A HUGE TRANSITION --
MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY.
A A LOT OF OUR SERVICE MEMBERS
ARE COMING HOME WITHOUT LEGS
WITHOUT ARMS AND THOSE OF
VISIBLE WOUNDS BUT THERE ARE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS THAT ARE COMING HOME
BECAUSE OF JUST THE ADAPTION.
BETWEEN WHAT THEY JUST WENT
THE BACK INTO THE WORLD REAL
WORLD.
NIGHTMARES -- ARGUMENTS FAMILY
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT THEY
WERE -- AWAY FROM AND HAD TO
ADJUSTING TO A DIFFERENT
LIFESTYLE HAS TO COME BACK INTO
THE MEANING OF LIFE.
AND THAT IS A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TRANSITION SO I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
AWARENESS TO THIS I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS I'M
RESOLUTION FORWARD.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE EVERYONE --
TO VOTE AYE.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY SUPPORTERS ARE
FIFTY AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
TODAY AND ALL THOSE WHO SERVE
THIS GREAT COUNTRY WHO
ACKNOWLEDGES STAYS A VERY
SPECIAL DAY.
I'M HONORED TO BE CO AUTHOR AND
AND I'M SO PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT.
THE AWARENESS IS FINALLY COMING
FORWARD AS IT SHOULD.
SO MANY OF OUR VETERANS ARE
EXPERIENCING PTSD BECAUSE OF
THEIR SERVICE THAT WE'VE ASKED.
FOR THEM TO GIVE TO US.
WHEN THEY RETURN HOME THEY
SHOULD BE DOING IT?
AND WE SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
HELP THEM.
IN THE TRANSITION.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK AND I
PERSONALLY WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE MEN AND WOMEN IN OUR
HOSPITALS THE VA HOSPITALS WHO
WORK WITH THESE VETERANS EVERY
SINGLE DAY THE CONCERTS THE
NURSES.
AND OF COURSE THE FAMILIES.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
AWARE OF WHAT EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENS WITH WITH THE TRANSITION.
SO MANY THESE GI AS THEY COME
HOME BOTH MEN AND WOMEN.
AND THIS IS NOT JUST THE MALE
SIDE THIS IS MEN AND WOMEN
BECAUSE WOMEN ARE ASKED -- TO BE
INVOLVED IN SO MANY COMBAT
SITUATIONS TODAY BUT WHEN THEY
COME HOME MR FAMILIES HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IT.
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE OFTEN TO
THE CORNER AND WHEN THE LIGHTS
GO DOWN.
THEY WON'T COME OUT.
OR THEY GET IN A CROWD WHEN THEY
SEE THEIR THEIR THEIR FRIENDS
AND FAMILY THEY WANT TO STAY
AWAY.
WITH THE FRAYED TO TAKE THEIR
THEIR SMALL CHILD TO SCHOOL.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THE
NOISE IN HERE THE FOURTH OF JULY
IS JUST AROUND THE CORNER.
AND THE SOUNDS OF THE FIRE
CRACKERS AND SO ON IT IS AMAZING
WHAT THEY GO THROUGH.
IN THE TRANSITION AND SO MANY OF
THEM STAY HOME AND THEY REFUSED.
TO GO TO THE VA BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT ONCE THEY GET THERE.
THINGS MIGHT CHANGE.
IN HE NEGATIVE TO THEM BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT.
THAT MEANS THEY HAVE TO START
DRINKING OR TOP USING DRUGS
WHATEVER IT IS AND THEY TURN TO
THOSE THINGS.
SO I KNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT.
OUR MEN AND WOMEN NEED HELP PTSD
IS SOMETHING THAT -- SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND IT KNOWLEDGE BY ALL OF US IN
SOCIETY THAT WE NEED TO HELP OUR
MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM.
IN TO EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY CAN
GOOD KNOWLEDGE OR SEE THEIR
SERVICE THERE TRULY THE HEROES
OF OUR COUNTRY AND THANK YOU.
I AND I SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND I URGE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATE ARCHULETA
SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTH
COAST HERE BRING IN THIS FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE -- IN
ADDITION TO THE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO SERVE IN OUR ARMED
FORCES.
IT.
DOES BEAR MENTIONING THAT OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS THOSE FIGHTING
THE FIRES.
PULLING PEOPLE OUT OF CARS WHEN
THEY'RE INJURED.
DEALING WITH ISSUES OF VIOLENCE
ON OUR STREETS EVERY DAY -- THE
TRAUMA AND THE INJURIES
[inaudible]
NOT JUST.
A DISORDER PTSD BUT IT'S ALSO
POST TRAUMATIC STRESS INJURY.
AND THAT INJURY IS JUST AS
SERIOUS AS ANY PHYSICAL HARM.
A SHOULDER AND KNEE WHEN YOUR
MIND IS PSYCHOLOGICALLY DAMAGED.
THAT INJURY CAN BE HEALED AND
THIS IS A YEAR WHERE WE'VE GOT
TO DE STIGMATIZE -- THIS ISSUE
AND LET PEOPLE COME FORWARD AND
TALK ABOUT THOSE VERY COMMON
EVERYDAY INJURIES THAT SCAR US
ALL SO WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION CENTER
MCGUIRE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN IWANT
TO RECOGNIZE -- ALL OF THOSE WHO
SERVED WHETHER YOU ARE IN THE
SENATE AND I NEGLECTED TO
MENTION MISS MCNULTY AS WELL --
FOR HER LONG SERVICE -- IN THE
MILITARY AND IN JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND ABOUT.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DALY [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE AYE JACKSON AYE
JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK I'M REAL.
AYE NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
I AM BURKE HI HI [inaudible]
STERN AYE.
LIKE US HE I WINNER.
HI WILK HI HI [inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBER ALLEN.
HI.
OKAY I HAVE THIRTY SEVEN EYES --
ZERO KNOWS THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED AND CENTER MCGUIRE YOU
ROUGH FOR THE PRESENTATION OF
YOUR GAS THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS AT IT
IS AN HONOR TO BE ARE INTRODUCED
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO.
WORK EVERY DAY.
ON BEHALF OF VETERANS IN THIS
STATE.
JOHN STEVENS IS THE MARIN COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICER.
HE ACTUALLY CAME TO OUR OFFICE
AND SAID WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE.
RECOGNIZE THE ISSUE PTSD IN THE
STATE OR TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU MISTER STEVENS NOT
JUST FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO
VETERANS BUT FOR HIS SERVICE IN
THE MILITARY AND WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL.
THAT MISTER LANDER WAS HERE
TODAY HE'S A CINEMA COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICER WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR SERVICE IF
YOU CAN GIVE THEM A WARM WELCOME
AND PLEASE JOIN US FOR A PICTURE
RECOGNIZING PTSD.
AWARENESS IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUING WITH A PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR -- SENATOR.
SENATE MITCHELL ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN MISTER PRESIDENT I
AM AND YOU MAY PROCEED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY BY SENATOR MITCHELL
RELATIVE TO BE BE MORE CAMPBELL
NATIONAL MINORITY MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH.
CENTER MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES CLEARLY WE'VE GOT A
COMMON THEME THIS MORNING I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY WHICH RECOGNIZES THE MONTH
OF JULY AS THE B. B. MORE
CAMPBELL NATIONAL MINORITY
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST THIS MONTH COLLEAGUES WE
CELEBRATE THE ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FREEDOM OF AFTER AMERICANS FROM
SLAVERY IN THE ACHIEVEMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR LGBT Q.
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THE INNER
SEXUAL IDENTITIES WITHIN THESE%
COMMUNITIES.
AND DURING THE CELEBRATIONS AS
WE HIGHLIGHTED THE SUCCESS OF
THESE COMMUNITIES WE'VE ALSO
DISCUSS HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES INCLUDING ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
IT'S WELL KNOWN THE PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY USE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT MUCH
LOWER RATES DUE TO LACK OF
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE.
THE LINGERING STIGMA OF MENTAL
ILLNESS IN SOCIETY.
AND NOT ONLY EXPLICIT BIAS AMONG
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS BUT ALSO
THE LACK OF CULTURAL COMPETENCY
BY MANY.
LATINO NATIVE AMERICAN THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES
REPORT HIGHER RATES OF SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERING SUICIDE COMPARED TO
THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS.
WHILE AFRICAN AMERICANS REPORT
ALMOST TWICE AS MANY SUICIDE
ATTEMPTS.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE THE LATE B.
B. MORE CAMPBELL WHO TIRELESS
TIRELESSLY ADVOCATED FOR
COMMUNITY SUPPORT AND OPEN
ACCESS TO EFFECTIVE TREATMENT
OPTIONS AND SERVICES.
B. B. WITH A CELEBRATED WRITER
AND JOURNALIST RADIO COMMENTATOR
EDUCATOR COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS AND
MOST NOTABLY.
THE CO FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS THE
URBAN LOS ANGELES CHAPTER.
MORE THAN TEN YEARS AGO MISS
CAMPBELL PUBLISHED HER NEW YORK
TIMES BESTSELLING NOVEL ENTITLED
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD.
AND HER CHILDREN'S BOOK
SOMETIMES MY MOMMY GETS ANGRY.
BOTH BOOKS YET I OPENING LIGHT.
ON THE PLIGHT OF PEOPLE
SUFFERING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND DISORDERS.
HE WAS A HERO FOR NAMI AND HER
LEGACY CONTINUES TODAY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU
SUPPORTED THAT C. R. SIXTY TO
ENHANCE PUBLIC AWARENESS AND THE
D. STIGMATIZATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH ILLNESSES.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
I DODD.
I THE RISE OF I GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
I OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK TIME REAL
[inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
OUR COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK HI.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBER [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED AND CENTER
MITCHELL I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
GUEST INTERVIEWS.
PRESIDENT INDEED I DO --
COLLEAGUES HERE TO WITNESS THE
PASSAGE OF THIS ALL IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION ALL ARE NOT ME
LEADERS FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
JESSICA CREWS IN STEVEN KITE THE
C. E. O. AND CO -- RESPECTIVELY
OF NON THE CALIFORNIA AND
CONSTITUENTS OF MINE HURLED
TURNER AND NANCY CARTER BOARD
MEMBERS AND CO FOUNDERS OF NOT
ME -- BEEN LOS ANGELES PLEASE
WELCOME THEM TO THE SENATE FLOOR
.
MISTER BRADFORD FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE -- MISS PRESIDENT
FOR PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU SEE OUR MEMBERS HI
IT'S A PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE AND
WELCOME THE TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN UC DAVIS MANDELA
WASHINGTON FOLLOWS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. FOR
JOINING US TODAY IN THE GALLERY.
THAT MANDELA WASHINGTON
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM WAS CREATED
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR YOUNG
AFRICAN AMERICAN AFRICAN
PROFESSIONALS LEADERS FROM SUB
SAHARAN AFRICA.
THE PROGRAM EMPOWERS THE FELLOWS
TO ACADEMIC COURSEWORK
LEADERSHIP TRAINING AND NETWORK
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE TWENTY
FIVE HERE TODAY THAT HAVE
FOCUSED THEIR ATTENTION ON
PUBLIC MANAGEMENT WITH EMPHASIS
ON CIVIC ENGAGEMENT RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT.
AND FISCAL OF FINANCIAL -- ARE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE FELLOWS ARE HERE TODAY ARE
FROM THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE TO
THIRTY FIVE AND HAVE ESTABLISHED
RECORDS OF ACCOMPLISHMENT AND
PROMOTING INNOVATION AND
POSITIVE IMPACT.
IN THEIR ORGANIZATIONS
INSTITUTIONS COMMUNITIES AND
COUNTRIES THE FELLOW FOLLOWING
ON ACADEMIC COMPONENTS OF THE
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM THEY WILL
VISIT A WASHINGTON DC FOR SUMMIT
FEATURE NETWORKING AND A PANEL
DISCUSSION WITH US LEADERS.
FROM THE PUBLIC PRIVATE AND
NONPROFIT SECTORS ONE RETURNING
TO THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
THE FELLOWS CONTINUE TO BUILD
THE SKILLS THEY HAVE DEVELOPED
WHILE A SPENDING THEIR TIME IN
THE UNITED STATES THROUGH THESE
EXPERIENCES TO MANDELA
WASHINGTON FOLLOWS HAVE ACCESS
TO ONGOING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
AND NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL AS SUPPORT FOR THEIR IDEALS
BUSINESSES AND ORGANIZATIONS
THERE FROM OVER TWENTY COUNTRIES
SUCH AS GABBY -- GONNA SEE YOUR
LOAN -- ETHIOPIA NIGERIA SOUTH
AFRICA THE CONGO REPUBLIC --
KENYA BOTSWANA MORE THAN BIG
ETHIOPIA MEMBERS LET'S GIVE A
WARM CENTER WELCOME.
THE CENTER BRADFORD.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES.
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
FIRST A MEMBERS I MOVE THE
ADOPTION OF AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THAT CROSS THE DESK ON FRIDAY.
JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
BE ADOPTED PUBLISHED AND
RETURNED TO COMMITTEE.
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU IN ADDITION I HAVE ONE
OTHER OF MOTION I MOVE THE
ADOPTION.
OF FLOOR AMENDMENTS TO A. B.
WHAT -- ONE HUNDRED THAT CROSS
THE DESK ON FRIDAY JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
THANK YOU MISTER MAJORITY LEADER
WILL TAKE THOSE SEPARATELY OKAY
GROWTH.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE.
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S ASPIRIN
AYE VOTE -- CENTER GROVE IS ASK
FOR NO VOTE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL THE FIRST.
ONE YES LOSE IT ON THE FIRST ONE
WHICH IS [inaudible]
THE AMENDMENTS.
THE AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
[inaudible]
MISTER SECRETARY [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS.
NO BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
I THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I HUESO.
I OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS.
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY.
HI WIENER.
AYE.
WILK NO NO [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
OKAY.
YES IS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN
THE MOTION CARRIES NOW WILL MOVE
ON TO THIS THE SECOND MOTION
WHICH IS -- FOR MINUTES
REGARDING AB ONE HUNDRED THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE CENTER GROVE IS ASKING
FOR KNOW ABOUT MISTER SECRETARY.
IF YOU'RE.
IS -- THAT'S GOOD IDEAS --
OBJECTION TO USING THE PREVIOUS.
ROLL CALL VOCAL.
SEEING NONE AYE AYES TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS.
TEN MOTION CARRIES.
THE CORNER OF NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO THE CONSIDERATION THE
DAILY FILE.
HOME OKAY UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
WHEN OUR THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM?
ONE SIX EIGHT AB EIGHT NINE SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOVE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU SIR REALLY NOTED
[inaudible]
SENATOR ALLEN.
I MISS PRESIDENT FOR YOU SEE
THIS MORNING.
EITHER BECAUSE THE AUTHOR WOULD
LIKE TO BE.
REMOVED FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
NINE THIS AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOR
HER NOT TO RESOURCES FROM THE
CONSENT COUNTER PLACED ON THE
INACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER HUESO.
THE IF UNDER MOST OF MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS PLEASE MOVE FILE
ITEM THIRTY FIVE S. C. R.. FIFTY
SEVEN TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU DULY NOTED CENTER DODD.
OTHER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS --
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR --
REMOVE -- IT AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
NINETY FROM THE CONSENT AND
PLACED ON INACTIVE.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER BRADFORD.
YES AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE FALLOUT ITEM ONE
SEVENTY A. B. NINE THIRTEEN FROM
THE CONCERNED COLLAR IN PLACE ON
AN ACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
EMOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE AB EIGHT SIXTY NINE FROM
THE CONSENT FILE.
THANK YOU SIR CENTRE BELL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- IS
CHRIS TO AUTHORIZE US REMOVE --
AB -- TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THIS
IS FILE ITEM A ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU EITHER [inaudible]
SENATE RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM ONE SIX SIX AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE REVIEWS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ADDRESSING CHAPTER
IN OUT CONFLICTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER MIKE'S UP WE
WILL MOVE TO THE CONSIDERATION
THE DAILY FILE -- SECOND READING
ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWENTY FIVE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
A SOME OF ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN
WITH THE MOMENT. FOR NINETY
EIGHT EIGHT OH SEVEN WITH A
MOMENT FIVE FIFTY TWO WITH A
MOMENT 1-650-134-0911 THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE SECOND READING
WILL BE DEEMED READ WE MOVED TO
SENATE THIRD READING.
ITEM [inaudible]
THIRTY SIX JUST [inaudible]
SENATOR GLAZER.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
GLAZER RELATIVE TO USE NON SMALL
CELL LUNG CANCER AWARENESS WEEK.
THERE GLAZER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS -- THE
RESOLUTION THAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY.
MEMBERS FOCUSES ON INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH NON
SMALL CELL LUNG CANCER -- AS
MANY HERE ON THE FLOOR NO LONG
CANCERS IS CURRENTLY THE LEADING
CANCER KILLER IN THE UNITED
STATES -- BUT IMPORTANTLY
ROUGHLY 20% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
DIE FROM LUNG CANCER.
HAVE NEVER SMOKED THAT'S RIGHT
20%.
NEVER SMOKED TWO THIRDS OF THE
NON SMOKERS.
WHO ARE DIAGNOSED ARE WOMEN?
AND ASIAN WOMEN ARE AT A HIGHER
RISK OF BEING DIAGNOSED THAN.
THAN ANY OTHER WOMAN.
IN MY DISTRICT LAST YEAR WE
LEARN OF THE TRAGIC PASSING OF A
VERY PROMINENT -- ASIAN AMERICAN
LEADER THE CITY COUNCIL WOMAN
FROM THE TOWN OF URAGA.
PASSED AWAY FROM THIS EXACT
DISEASE A NON SMOKER -- AND IT
ENDED RAISE A LOT OF AWARENESS
OF THIS PROBLEM -- AND THAT LACK
OF AWARENESS TO THIS ISSUE IN
AND OF IN A FEW MINUTES OF AN
ENERGY IS THE FAMILY OF THAT --
THAT COUNCILMEMBER TO YOU ALL.
BUT THIS RESOLUTION SIX TO
EXPAND AWARENESS INTO NEW INYO --
THERAPY CHEMOTHERAPY TARGET
THERAPY TREATMENTS FOR NON SMALL
CELL LUNG CANCER PATIENTS.
THIS RESOLUTION DEBT THIS
RESOLUTION DEDICATE THE WEEK OF
JUNE TWENTY FOURTH TO JUNE.
THIRTY AS NON SMALL CELL LUNG
CANCER AWARENESS WEEK I WANT TO
THANK THE SEVENTEEN SENATE CO
AUTHORS HERE ON THE FLOOR.
ON THIS RESOLUTION WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HEARING NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
[inaudible]
ANY OBJECTIONS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ALL YOU HAVE GOT THE IDEA YOU
HAD A GAS.
YES SIR GLAZER YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I MENTIONED THE
COUNCIL WOMAN HER NAME IS GENET.
FRISKY.
AND IN HONOR OF HER PASSING HER
HUSBAND ROBERT FRISKY -- STARTED
THE GENET FRISKY FOUNDATION.
IT'S AN ORGANIZATION IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WHICH IS
MAKING GREAT EFFORTS TO EDUCATE
AND CREATE AWARENESS ON THIS
ISSUE.
HERE IN THE GALLERY IS -- ROBERT
FRISKY AND THEIR SON PATRICK AND
WHEN IT IS SENT TO YOU ASKED THE
SENATE TO WELCOME THEM TO OUR
CHAMBER TO THANK THEM FOR THEIR
WORK.
IN THIS IMPORTANT AREA WELCOME
TO THE SENATE.
THANK YOU SIR GLAZER NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WILL BE TAKING UP ITEMS.
844-064-0950 1-596-074-7580 ONE
EIGHTY THREE AND EIGHTY FIVE SO
MOVED TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY SENATOR HERTZBERG WAS
MISSING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
PRESIDENT BOB I'M SORRY
SECRETARY PLEASE HELP ME PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACT REALLY INTO ELECTIONS.
CENTER HERTZBERG THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT SO MUCH OF
THE HISTORY IS WE'VE URBANIZED
IN THIS COUNTRY.
BOB WE'VE HAD PEOPLE WHO'VE
LIVED IN WHAT WAS CALLED WALK
UPS.
THEY HAD THEIR STORE FRONT WHERE
THEY OFTEN DO THEIR BUSINESS AND
UPSTAIRS THEY LIVED.
WE SEE MORE RECENTLY SHIFTS BACK
TO WHAT WE USED TO HAVE MANY
YEARS AGO FIGURE IN THE EASTERN
PART OF THE COUNTRY.
WHERE PEOPLE LIVE WHERE THEY
WORK?
WELL THAT CREATES A CHALLENGE
BECAUSE THE LAW SAYS IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN'T REGISTER TO
VOTE.
WHERE YOU WORK?
WELL IF YOU ALSO LIVE THERE IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
LIVE WORK PLACES AND THE LIKE --
IT CREATES A PROBLEM SO WHAT
WE'VE DONE HERE WHAT IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ IS DONE HERE.
IS BASICALLY CLARIFIED THE LAW
THAT SAYS.
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE TO LIVE THERE
BUT WE FIND OFTEN THAT OF
REGISTERED VOTERS WON'T ALLOW
PEOPLE TO REGISTER IN PLACES
THAT ARE LOOK APPEARED TO BE
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES WHAT IN
FACT THEY'RE ALSO ZONED AND
PEOPLE ARE LIVING THERE.
CLEARLY YOU HAVE TO LIVE THERE
BUT THIS CLARIFIES THAT PIECE OF
THE LAW I ASKED YOU I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHANGED [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GONZALEZ HI.
GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
LEYVA.
I AM.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NOVEMBER.
OUR COUNTY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK HI HI.
THE SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BURGESS
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN PAN.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
HI.
TWENTY SIX NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM FORTY FOUR
SENATOR DORADO.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA AND ACT REALLY
INTO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
I JUST START [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS AB FIVE FOURTEEN
INCREASES THE INCREASES THE
VOTING RIGHTS OF THE STUDENT
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
BOARD OF TRUSTEES BY REMOVING
THE NON VOTING STATUS OF ONE OF
THE TWO STUDENT MEMBERS THERE BY
GIVING BOTH STUDENTS VOTING
RIGHTS.
IN THE TIME BETWEEN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE STUDENT POPULATION
GREW TO OVER. FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND NEARLY DOUBLING
THE STUDENT POPULATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
IT IS MUCH MORE DIVERSE NOW AND
THAT DIVERSITY REQUIRES THE
OPPORTUNITY THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
FOR DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
REPRESENTED THROUGH A VOTE OF
THE TRUSTEES.
THE STUDENT TRUSTEES EXERCISE A
CRUCIAL VOTE A REPRESENTING ALL
STUDENTS ON THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES IT IS A SIMPLE AND
REASONABLE STEP.
THAT SEEKS TO RATIONALLY
INCREASE THE POWER OF THE
STUDENT VOICE ON THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE I BOOK.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO.
SEEING OF ANY FOR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN [inaudible]
BY ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
HI FOR JUST.
BY BRADFORD I COUNTY AT ALL
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DALY [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ.
I GROW [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE HER TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
HI NELSON [inaudible]
PAN PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE [inaudible]
BOB AKOWSKI [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK HI.
WIENER AYE WILK AYE ROTH AYE.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BATES
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN PAN. FIVE THREE SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
CENTER JACKSON ARE YOU PREPARED
MR SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AND ACT GOING TO
FAMILY LAW CENTER JACKSON THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
THIS IS THE LEGISLATURE'S ANNUAL
FAMILY LAW OMNIBUS BILL.
IT MAKES A NUMBER OF NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES AND
CORRECTIONS TO FAMILY LAW IN
CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE CLARIFYING
THE TIME FRAME FOR CHALLENGING A
SPOUSE'S PRESUME PARENTS --
PARENTAGE IT REMOVES.
PLEASE PROCEEDS THAT I CAN I
KNOW THIS IS FASCINATING STUFF
SO -- IT ALSO REMOVES GENDER
TERMS IS APPROPRIATED UPDATES
AND CORRECT VERY STATUTORY
REFERENCES -- AND IT WAS.
A CONSENT ITEM PULLED OFF
CONSENT ONLY TO ADD CHAPTER RING
OUT AMENDMENTS THE BILL IS HAD
NO NO VOTES.
IT HAS A WIDE VARIETY OF SUPPORT
AND A NO OPPOSITION WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN
[inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES.
BELL.
I PURCHASED.
I BRADFORD BY CAMBIADO.
I CHANGE [inaudible]
BY DAILY.
I DODD.
BY THE ROUTE SO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I HER TITLE.
I JACKSON I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS HE AYE WIENER
AYE WILK.
HI.
MISTER CHAIR AND MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN PAN. FIVE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM FORTY NINE SENATOR
DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION FOR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
RELATIVE TO FIREARMS CENTER DIED
TO PRESIDENT SENATORS I RISE TO
PRESENT AJ.
ARE FOR ASA PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR
AJ ARE FOR URGES CONGRESS TO
SWIFTLY PASSED HOUSE RESOLUTION.
EIGHT THE BIPARTISAN BACKGROUND
CHECK ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN HERE CALIFORNIA WE'VE
ALREADY PASSED LAWS TO REQUIRE
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THIS LAW HELPS REDUCE THE
TRAGEDIES OF GUN VIOLENCE BY
KEEPING FIRE ARMS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT
HAVE THEM.
HOWEVER UNTIL WE BRING THIS
COLLECTIVE EFFECTIVE FIREARM
POLICY TO THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
A LOOPHOLE REMAINS IN FEDERAL
GUN LAW FOR UNLICENSED SELLERS.
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE WAY TO
INSURE THE GUNS ARE NOT SOLD TO
PROHIBITED PEOPLE IS TO NATIONAL
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS AT
THE POINT OF TRANSFER.
OF ANY FIREARM.
BY PASSING AJ OUR FOR OUR
LEADERS IN CONGRESS AND OUR
PRESIDENT WILL RECEIVE THE
MESSAGE THE CALIFORNIA DEMANDS
THE SPEEDY PASSAGE INSIDE THE OF
CONGRATS CONGRESSMAN.
THOMPSON'S H. R. EIGHT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DELHI.
DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HI.
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
I TITLE.
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
I AM.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO REAL.
NO NIELSEN PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
NOVEMBER.
BY WORK OWSKI MY WIENER.
HI WILK.
NO.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BATES
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DELHI [inaudible]
NO.
NIELSEN PAN RUBIO.
HI.
HI TWENTY SEVEN NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
ONE SENATOR CAFIERO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND ACT REALLY TO
IMMIGRATION.
THERE CABALLERO THANK YOU MISTER.
OP PRO TEM AND SENATORS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AJ ARE NINE
WHICH CALLS FOR THE FAIR AND
JUST TREATMENT OF UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND ITS EMPLOYEES.
IMMIGRATIONS.
IMMIGRANTS ARE THE FOUNDATION OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
FROM THE FOOD ON OUR TABLES TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE
THE EC ECONOMICALLY SUCCESSFUL
STATE IT IS TODAY WITHOUT THE
LABORIOUS WORK IMMIGRANTS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED. TO IT OVER THE LAST
FEW CENTURIES.
LET US ALSO BE REMINDED THAT
WHETHER OUR ANCESTORS ARRIVED
HERE FOUR HUNDRED YEARS AGO OR
FOUR DAYS AGO WE ARE ALL
IMMIGRANTS TO THE UNITED STATES
AND FOR GOOD CAUSE.
OUR COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON THE
BELIEF OF OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
THE WHILE OUR PUBLIC DISCOURSE
MOTTOS AND MONUMENTS GRACIOUSLY
INVITE PEOPLE INTO THE UNITED
STATES FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
FOR THE CHANCE TO MAKE THEIR
LIVES BETTER.
IT IS BECOME ABRUPTLY CLEAR IN
RECENT YEARS AND MOST RECENTLY
THAT OUR GOVERNING PRACTICES DO
NOT REFLECT THIS VIRTUE THESE
WERE CHOICE VALUES.
THIS IS DISPLAYED BY THE FEDERAL
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON ENHANCING
PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE INTERIOR OF
THE UNITED STATES.
SIGNED ON JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHICH ALLOWS ICE TO
USE ALL EXECUTIVE BRANCH
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS TO AID
IN A REST UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
SINCE THEN ICE HAS ENGAGED IN
NUMEROUS PREDATORY AND DECEITFUL
TACTICS THAT ARE HURTING ARE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THESE PLOYS INCLUDE
OFFICIALS MAKING ARRESTS IN SAFE
PLACES LIKE COURT HOUSES AND
SCHOOLS.
AND UNLAWFULLY ANNOUNCING
THEMSELVES AS POLICE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF LANGUAGE BARRIERS
TO DECEIVE THOSE TARGETED.
THE BEHAVIOR OF THESE OFFICIALS
HAS UNDERMINED THE TRUST BETWEEN
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
THE VERY AGENCIES MEANT TO KEEP
US SAFE WHEN TRUST IS ERODED OUR
COMMUNITY SUFFER. FOR EXAMPLE
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR BEING
APPREHENDED BY ICE WORKPLACE
HAZARDS HEALTH VIOLATIONS AND
INJURIES GO UNREPORTED TO OSHA.
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR CANNOT
FULLY INVESTIGATE ILLEGAL
WORKPLACE PRACTICES BECAUSE
OFTEN THOSE WHO ARE EXPLOITED
ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND WILL NOT
FIBER FILE REPORTS.
DUE TO FEAR THIS PUTS ALL
EMPLOYEES AT RISK ADDITIONALLY
CRIMES ARE NOT REPORTED TO OUR
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DUE
TO THE UNCERTAINTY AND FEAR THAT
HAS BEEN CREATED.
THESE ON REPORTED CRIMES MAKE
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND SAFE NOT
JUST OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
DESPITE THIS FACT WE HAVE TAKEN
STEPS TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
LOCALLY IN CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH LEGISLATION I SAYS
CONTINUE TO DEPLOY THESE
SHAMEFUL RUSSES IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL THEREFORE THIS RESOLUTION
URGES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
INSTRUCT ICE TO STOP THE
DECEITFUL AND DANGEROUS PLOYS
AGAINST IMMIGRANTS.
AS WELL AS TO ADOPT UNIFORM
STANDARDS BY WHICH ICE OFFICERS
CAN HUMANELY OPERATE ONCE THESE
HARMFUL BEHAVIORS ARE CORRECTED
IT'S MY HOPE THE CALIFORNIA CAN
FOSTER THE GROWTH OF TRUST.
BETWEEN OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
AND OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS ONCE
AGAIN.
AS IF THERE EVER WAS A STATE WHO
RELIED SO HEAVILY ON THE WORK.
WORK ETHIC HARD MANUAL LABOR AND
DETERMINATION OF IMMIGRANTS IT
IS CALIFORNIA OUR STATE PROGRESS
IS A BEACON TO IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES LOOKING FOR SOCIAL
MOBILITY THROUGH HARD WORK.
SOCIAL MOBILITY THAT FUELS
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC VIBRANCY
CULTURAL RICHNESS AND STAFF
STATUS AS A WORLD LEADER THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
SENATOR GROWTH.
ALL YOU FOR YOUR MIKE DOWN WAS A
OKAY SEEING SEEING -- NINE
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
NO DEL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED.
NO BRADFORD.
HI COMING YELLOW [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY.
NO DODD.
I THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ HI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
BY WITH SO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NUMBER RAIL.
NO NIELSEN.
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
BY STONE.
NO -- BURKE.
IOWA CASKEY BY WIENER AYE WILK.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS CHIANG
[inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I NIELSEN PAN WILK.
HI TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS A EIGHT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE SENATOR MINING.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE AN
ACT GOING TO TAXATION.
MR A CENTER MONEY THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB SIX
EIGHTEEN IS A DISTRICT BILL THAT
WILL ALLOW THE CITY OF SCOTTS
VALLEY.
AND EMERYVILLE TO EXCEED THE 2%
SALES TAX CAP BY A QUARTER OF
ONE CENT.
THIS BILL INCLUDES LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRES THESE INCREASES TO BE
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS OF THE
CITY'S BOTH CITIES HAVE
COMPLETED FISCAL REVIEWS AND
HAVE IDENTIFIED THESE INCREASES
TO BE CRITICAL. TO CONTINUING.
SOCIAL AND CRITICAL SERVICES IN
THOSE CITIES THE LEGISLATURE
MOST RECENTLY APPROVED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION FOR THE CITIES OF
BERKELEY IN NORTH LAKE TAHOE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MONEY.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
SB SIX ONE EIGHT IS SORT OF A
NOTIFICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
THAT CITIES ARE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME.
AND WE SHOULD KINDA TAKE NOTE OF
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
STRUGGLING AND NOT ABLE.
TO MEET THEIR BUDGETS BECAUSE OF
RISING PENSION COSTS
AND IT SHOULD BEHOOVE US TO
MAYBE EVEN SET UP A SPECIAL
COMMISSION TO START.
SEEING WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
OUR CITIES THAT ARE NOW.
ASKING THEIR VOTERS TO GO BEYOND
THE BRADLEY BURNS IN THE SALES
TAX LIMITATIONS.
BUT JUST BRING THAT UP AS A
POINT OF INFORMATION MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR MORE.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE MISTER MOM I CENTER MONEY
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
I PORGES NO BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DALLY.
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ.
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL.
I WAS SO.
BY -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NOTE LEYVA.
BUY MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE.
NO NIELSEN.
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NOVEMBER.
BY CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS COPY AT ALL
[inaudible]
MURTADA [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN PAN.
ROTH [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WILK.
HI TWENTY THREE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
SENATOR BRADFORD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THIS THING.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND ACT GOING TO METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT'S.
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT -- AB ONE TWENTY DEALS
WITH THE NUMBER OF SEATS ON THE
METROPOLITAN WALLER WATER
DISTRICT A DISTRICT THAT WAS
FORMED IN NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
AND IT WAS.
BASED ON THE SAYS VALUES --
EVALUATION OF PROPERTY.
AND THAT'S HOW THEY DETERMINE
THEIR SEATS TODAY -- THE
METROPOLITAN -- DISTRICT NO
LONGER IS FUNDED THROUGH
PROPERTY TAXES BUT CONTINUES TO
USE THE SAME ABOUT A METHOD THAT
WAS DOUBTLESS. EIGHTY YEARS AGO --
SIMPLY PUT THIS BILL WILL HELP
INSURE SOME OF THE HIGH
DEVELOPED IN DENSE URBAN
COMMUNITIES DO NOT LOSE
REPRESENTATION ON THE
METROPOLITAN WATER BOARD.
AB ONE TWENTY IT WILL ACHIEVE
THAT GOAL BY WALKING IN THE
CURRENT NUMBER OF SEATS FOR EACH
DISTRICT OF THE METROPOLITAN
WATER BORDERS PER CLASS FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER AT BRADFORD ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
MEASURE PASSES ICE THIRTY SEVEN
NO.
ZERO NOW WILL PROCEED TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR DODD.
ARE YOU READY TO CALL HAVES THE
SECRETARY READ IF YOU ARE -- YES.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
ENACT WILLING TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR DIED.
MISTER PRESIDENT THERE ARE MANY
CUSTOMERS WHO FOR PRIVACY OR
PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS HAVE
THEIR PHONE NUMBERS UNLISTED.
FOR AN PUBLISHED.
ALL THE PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS
CAN CONTACT THESE NUMBERS TO
RESPOND TO AN EMERGENCY THEY ARE
NOT ABLE TO TEST THEIR SYSTEMS
WITH THESE NUMBERS.
BEFOREHAND.
AB TEN SEVENTY NINE WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO TEST
EMERGENCY ALERTS ON UNLISTED AN
UNPUBLISHED PHONE NUMBERS BEFORE
AN EMERGENCY OCCURS.
AT A TIME A DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES RAVAGING OUR STATE IT
IS CRUCIAL THAT ALLCALIFORNIA'S
RECEIVE EMERGENCY.
COMMUNICATIONS THIS BILL IS BI
PARTISAN HAS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU CENTER DIED ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE MEASURE PASSES
THIRTY SEVEN EYES NOSE.
ZERO MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR ROBB
MISTERS.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ AND
AQUINNAH FARMS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT HONORABLY
RETIRED UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS.
HAVE SIMILAR RIGHTS TO OTHER
PEACE OFFICERS INCLUDING THEIR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
COUNTERPARTS.
CURRENT LAW PERMITS HONORABLY
RETIRED PEACE OFFICERS TO CARRY
A CONCEALED WEAPON DUE TO THEIR
ADVANCED TRAINING AND SERVICE.
TO THE COMMUNITY.
ON HONORABLY RETIRED DESIGNATION
MEANS THEY ACCEPT A SERVICE OR
DISABILITY RETIREMENT.
AND THEY RECEIVE AN ID CARD TO
PROVE THEIR STATUS.
THIS ISSUE AROSE BECAUSE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
DOES NOT HAVE A DISABILITY
RETIREMENT CATEGORY.
SIMILAR TO THE CALPERS%
RETIREMENT SYSTEM INSTEAD
OFFICERS ARE KATTER CATEGORIZES
INJURED AND MEDICALLY SEPERATED
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS AS DUTY DISABILITY
INCOME RECIPIENTS. FOR EXAMPLE.
VALLEY JACOBS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
PEACE OFFICER WHO HELPED RESCUE
KIDNAPPING VICTIM JAYCEE DUGARD.
SUFFERED AN ON DUTY INJURY IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN AND ACCEPTED
DUTY DISABILITY INCOME.
SHE HAS CONTINUALLY BEEN DENIED
ON HONORABLY RETIRED
IDENTIFICATION CARD.
AND A CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT.
THIS BILL WOULD FIX THAT
TECHNICAL DISCREPANCY IN ALLOW
THESE RETIRED [inaudible]
SKIMMING.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS SIMILAR TREATMENT AS
OTHER PEACE OFFICERS AROUND THE
STATE SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ROTH ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER JACKSON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
AS MANY OF US HAVE READ WITH
HORROR AN INCIDENT THAT OCCURRED
ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO DOWN IN
CORONA.
WHERE AN OFF DUTY POLICE OFFICER
CARRYING A CONCEALED FIREARM
SHOT AND KILLED A FELLOW AND
SERIOUSLY INJURED HIS FAMILY?
AT A COSTCO.
AT A TIME WHEN WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT DE ESCALATING SITUATIONS
OF VIOLENCE WHY IN THE WORLD ARE
WE ADDING TO THE LIST OF PEOPLE
WHO CAN CONTINUE TO CARRY
CONCEALED FIREARMS.
AND I JUST -- I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT OUR UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICERS ARE
TRAINED BUT MY QUESTION IS WHY
ARE WE ADDING MORE PEOPLE TO THE
LIST TO CAN CARRY CONCEALED
WEAPONS.
AND IN AN INSTANCE LIKE THIS
WHEN DE ESCALATION MOST LIKELY
WOULD HAVE SAVE LIVES HERE HE
WAS WITH A LOADED WEAPON IN HAND
WHICH HE CHOSE TO USE THAT ENDED
THE LIFE OF ONE INDIVIDUAL
OUTSIDE A COSTCO. FOR PETE'S
SAKE.
AND THE KIND OF THIS KIND OF
ATTITUDE WHERE WE ARE REACH FOR
THE GUN FIRST AND IF YOU HAVE A
GUN AVAILABLE THE LAST THING
SADLY THAT SOME OF THESE FOLKS
ARE GOING TO DO.
IS TRY TO WALK AWAY FROM A
DANGEROUS SITUATION I FIND NO
JUSTIFICATION TO IT TO ALLOW FOR
AND ENCOURAGE THE INCREASE OF
THESE CONCEALED WEAPONS.
AND FOR THAT REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MEN WOMEN I SURE OF WORTH ON A
RELATED DISTINCTLY.
THEY HAVE GIVEN.
THEIR TIME RIGHT NOW WE JUST
RECENTLY TODAY AS A MATTER OF
FACT WE'RE BEARING ONE OF OUR
OWN.
TARA IS NOW LAID TO REST WITH
HONOR.
AND I THINK IT IS REFLECTIVE AND
ALL THE MEN AND WOMEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO HAVE GIVEN THEIR
LIVES.
WHO SUPPORT AND PROTECT US EACH
AND EVERY DAY THAT CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT PROTECT THIS?
IS A CONTINUATION OF THEIR DUTY
TO RECEIVE THAT.
THAT CERTIFICATE THE BADGE AND
AND TO BE ABLE TO CARRY THE
FIREARM AFTER RETIREMENT.
AND BECAUSE OF THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT I'VE SHARED WITH WHO I KNOW.
PERSONALLY THEY'VE ALWAYS DONE
THE RIGHT THING AND YES THERE'S
ALWAYS.
ONE BUT THINK ABOUT THE
THOUSANDS EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT
DO THE RIGHT THING WITH THAT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL NOT URGENT I
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEN ARCHULETA CENTER
GROWTH.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
FOR SEVERAL REASONS I THINK IT'S
OBVIOUSLY CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BEAR ARMS BUT AND I UNDERSTAND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA'S ARGUMENT ABOUT HAVING
TO FIRE ARMS ON CAMPUS.
BUT I I ADDRESS THE THE DOUGLAS
OF THE SYSTEM AND DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL ISSUE.
AND THE REASON WHY I SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE THEY HAD ARMED PEOPLE
AVAILABLE THERE.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE IN A SITUATION
WHERE SOMEONE IS FIRING FIRING
AT YOU.
I'M WAITING FOR NINE ONE ONE TO
RESPOND OR WAITING FOR AN
OFFICER TO GO ACROSS CAMPUS. TO
TO DEFEND YOU ARE SAVE YOU IS --
SECONDS COUNT AND FOR THOSE
PEOPLE TO GET TO AT THAT VERY
MOMENT.
AND THE PEOPLE OF A SMALL NARROW
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY AUTHORIZES ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TRAINED THEY'RE MOST
LIKELY POST CERTIFIED.
SO THEY HAVE THE TRAINING NEEDED
IN ORDER TO ENGAGE PROPERLY WITH --
INDIVIDUALS IN CASE SOMETHING
HAPPENS AND TO RESTRICT THEM
FROM BEING ABLE NOT TO HAVE A
CCW AND RESTRICT THEM FROM NOT
CARRYING ON CAMPUSES.
YOU KNOW ONE DAY THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE STUDENTS WHICH MOST
EVERYBODY CARES ABOUT OTHER
STUDENTS.
THEY'LL BE THE PERSON THAT
PROTECTS THEM BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH AND I BRING UP THE SCHOOL
AGAIN BACKES THE STONEMAN
DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL.
THE P. E. TEACHER THE DIM THE
GYM TEACHER USED HIS BODY. TO
BLOCK BULLETS BEING FIRED AT THE
STUDENTS SO THAT THE STUDENTS
WOULD BE SAFE DOWN A HALLWAY
THAT P. E. TEACHER SAVED MANY
STUDENTS LIVES.
NOW IN I KNOW A LOT OF YOU WILL
DISAGREE WITH ME I WOULD LOVE
FOR THAT P. E. TEACHER TO HAVE
GONE THROUGH A PRO CERTIFICATION
A CCW CLASS.
AND WHEN IN A LESS ACTIVE ENGAGE
SHOOTER WAS TRYING TO TAKE HIS
LIFE AND HIS STUDENTS LIFE I
WOULD HAVE LOVED FOR THAT P.
TEACHER TO BE ABLE TO DEFEND
HIMSELF IN A STUDENTS.
AND STILL BE ALIVE HERE TODAY
FOR HIS FAMILY.
SO I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR AND I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR ALSO
MAKING IT VERY NARROW AND NOT
BROAD SO THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD ADDRESSED.
IN A COLLEGIAL MANNER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR GROW SENATOR
JACKSON.
YES SO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
CORRECT -- IF I IF I MISSTATED
TO THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT ON DUTY POLICE OFFICERS
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT CAMPUS --
ISSUES I'M TALKING ABOUT RETIRED
OFF DUTY POLICE.
UC POLICE OFFICERS BEING GIVEN
THE RIGHT TO CARRY CONCEALED
WEAPONS WITH THEM.
AFTER THEY RETIRED ANYWHERE THEY
CHOOSE TO GO SO MY CONCERN IS.
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH WE HAVE
ENOUGH PROBLEMS -- WHEN WE HAVE
PEOPLE CARRYING CONCEALED
WEAPONS AND I THINK OF INSTANCES
WHERE WITH ALL THE BEST OF
INTENTIONS THE USE OF FIREARMS
ESCALATING SITUATIONS
UNNECESSARILY WHICH HAPPENED AT
THE SITUATION AND COSTCO WHICH
HAS HAPPENED IN OTHER PLACES?
ALSO WHEN YOU USE FIREARMS THE
RISK ASSOCIATED FOR EXAMPLE AT
THE BORDERLINE INCIDENT WHEN IT
WAS INDEED A C. H. P. BULLET.
THAT KILLED THE VENTURA COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFF WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES ISN'T THERE A BETTER
WAY.
AND CERTAINLY TO EXPAND
CONCEALED WEAPON KERRY TOP OFF
DUTY RETIRED.
POLICE OFFICERS IS NOT A AN
ATTEMPT.
TO MERGE THEIR GOOD WORK WHEN
THEY WERE ON DUTY BUT IT ASKS
THE QUESTION DO WE REALLY WANT
TO BE SEEING MORE AND MORE
FIREARMS.
IN PUBLIC PLACES AND WHAT IF WE
DO WE'RE GOING TO SEE MORE AND
MORE INSTANCES LIKE WE SAW THIS
COSCO JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
AND I FOR ONE DON'T BELIEVE THE
SECOND AMENDMENT ENCOURAGES THAT
OR PERMITS THAT.
I THINK IT'S A MATTER OF COMMON
SENSE WE NEED TO START REDUCING
DE ESCALATING ALL THE
HOSTILITIES THAT WE ARE SEEING
IN TODAY'S WORLD.
AND THAT IS THE REASON THAT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON CENTER
GALGIANI.
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I THINK THAT TODAY WE'RE
SEEING CONFLICT LIKE WE'VE NEVER
EVER SEEN BEFORE.
AND OUR OFFICERS ARE EXPOSED TO
A MUCH HIGHER LEVEL OF VIOLENCE.
I WENT TO JUST NOW TO LOOK UP TO
TELL YOU ABOUT A BLAST OF LIKE
NINE GANG MEMBERS AND IN THE
CITY OF STOCKTON A FEW DAYS AGO.
AND UP POPS AND IT'S SOMETHING
WHERE WE HAD ANOTHER PERSON
KILLED IN A SHOOTING LAST NIGHT
OUR OFFICERS WHETHER THEY'RE
POLICE OFFICERS ARE SHERIFF'S OR
UNIVERSITY OFFICERS THEY ARE
PUTTING THEMSELVES.
AT RISK AND THEY AFTER RETIRING
ARE OUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THEY SEE PEOPLE THAT THEY HAVE
ARRESTED OR OR THAT THEY HAVE.
OF CONFRONTED WHO ARE DOING
THINGS AGAINST THE LAW AND THEY
ARE AT RISK WHEN THEY DO SO AND
I ALSO SAY THIS AS SOMEONE WHO
LOST MY GODFATHER.
A RETIRED POLICE OFFICER HE WAS
STABBED TO DEATH A FEW YEARS AGO
AND THINGS LIKE THAT ARE NOT
FORGOTTEN HE SPENT MANY YEARS IN
THE COMMUNITY OF RESTING.
A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS AND IT'S
LIKELY THAT YOU RAN INTO
SOMEBODY WHO HE HAD ONCE
ARRESTED AND HE DIED OF VERY
DIALING VIOLENT DEATH.
SO I HAVE SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
HOPE YOU WILL.
TOO THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI
CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I I'D
LIKE TO ALLEVIATE MY COLLEAGUE
EVER CONCERN INSTEAD OF OUR
WRITING I REALLY DIDN'T TAKE
YOUR COMMENTS WRONG I UNDERSTOOD
WHAT YOU WERE SAYING.
BUT I JUST DON'T THINK THAT
SOMEONE WHO HAS SERVED -- THE
PUBLIC IN PUBLIC SAFETY POLICE
SHERIFFS AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SUCH ABOUT SAID.
AND IN OUR USE UNIVERSITY CAMPUS
JUST BECAUSE THEY HAVE RETIRED
IT DOESN'T DIMINISH THEIR
ABILITY OR QUALITY TO DEAL ARE
HAVE A FIREARM OR DE ESCALATE
SITUATIONS.
THE FIRST THING THAT WERE
TRAINED WHEN YOU APPLY FOR CCW
IS TO RE TREAT IF YOU CAN. TO
RETREAT IF YOU CAN THAT'S ONE OF
THE VERY FIRST THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRAINED SO I I APPLIED LIKE I
SAID THE AUTHOR FOR MAKING IT
VERY NARROW.
AND TO TO REALLY RECOGNIZE THAT
JUST BECAUSE OUR POLICE OFFICERS
HAVE RETIRED -- THEY REALLY HAVE
NOT LOST THE TRAINING AND THE
FORTITUDE TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH THE S. SITUATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF SENATOR
MONEY THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR THE
FLOOR TRACKING.
THROUGH THE CHAIR FIRE AWAY
QUESTION CENTER OFF.
THANK YOU SO.
I UNDERSTAND THE INTEREST
POTENTIALLY OF RECOGNIZING THE
TRAINING IN THE SERVICE OF THOSE
WHO NOW REACH THE AGE OF
RETIREMENT.
I'M CURIOUS IF THERE'S ANYTHING
IN THE BILL THAT REQUIRES
ONGOING CERTIFICATION OR
DETERMINATION OF MENTAL.
CAPACITY AS PEOPLE GET OLDER --
IN OUR SOCIETY PEOPLE DEAL WITH
DEMENTIA ALZHEIMERS.
OTHER PHYSICAL CONDITIONS THIS
ANYTHING IN THE BILL REQUIRE.
PERIODIC RE CERTIFICATION OR
MENTAL STATUS.
UPDATE WELL I'LL BE FRANK I'M
NOT SURE THAT I NECESSARILY KNOW
BUT IT IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT.
THIS IS A CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT
SO THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE
C. C. W. WERE I BELIEVE SOMEBODY
CAN CORRECT ME.
ARE REQUIRED TO FILL THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS OF ANYONE ELSE.
WITH A CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT
PERHAPS I CAN HAVE A LIFELINE
HERE FOR MY FORMER PEACE OFFICER
COLLEAGUES GOOD I APPRECIATE IT
THROUGH THE DAY HERE.
I AM A PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN YOUR C.
C. W. YOU HAVE TO BE CERTIFIED
EVERY YEAR YOU'VE GOT TO GO INTO
THE STATION.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO PROVE
THAT YOU CAN HANDLE IT AND ALSO
AS TIME GOES ON YES INDEED THERE
IS THAT POINT WHERE THEY HAVE
SAY OKAY NOW YOUR YOUR LITTLE
TOO OLD OR YOU HAVE SOME
PROBLEMS.
IF AND ALSO IF YOUR RETIRED
BECAUSE OF MENTAL STRESS OR
MENTAL ISSUES YOU'RE NOT
PERMITTED TO GET TO SEE CW AND
CARRY THE WEAPON.
THANK ALL THAT HE DOES RETIRED
IN GOOD PHYSICAL HEALTH WHO CAN
HANDLE IMPROVE THEIR CAPACITY TO
MAINTAIN THAT WEAPON.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND
IN THIS LEGISLATION.
THAT DOES CREATE THIS SPECIAL
RECOGNITION. FOR CERTAIN RETIRED
OFFICERS -- AND I REALIZE THE
FLOOR JACQUI ME NOT NO I HAVEN'T
READ ALL THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL.
YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT A CCW
PERMIT FOR ANYBODY.
INCLUDING THIS CATEGORY WOULD
REQUIRE ANNUAL RE CERTIFICATION
BUT IS THAT EXPLICIT IN THE BILL
OR IS THERE IT WILL THIS BE
CONSIDERED A WAIVER -- CARVE OUT
FOR THAT ANNUAL.
REVIEW WELL I CORRECT THIS THIS
IS SIMPLY A TECHNICAL CORRECTION
IT'S A SEMANTICS ISSUE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA VERSUS
ANY OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
IN THE STATE IF YOU ARE RETIRED
BECAUSE OF SERVICE OR RETIRED
BECAUSE OF DISABILITY A
DISABILITY RETIREMENT UNDER
CALPERS SYSTEM AS A RETIRED
POLICE OFFICER YOU ARE ENTITLED.
TO A CONCEALED KERRY.
PERMIT UNDER THE CONDITIONS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE SO APTLY DESCRIBED
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THE UC SYSTEM BECAUSE
FOR YOU KNOW THE UC SYSTEM IS A
SEPARATE RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
IT IS NOT CALPERS AND THE WAY
THEY CHARACTERIZE A DISABILITY
RETIREMENT THEY HAVE INTERPRETED
THAT AS NOT.
BECAUSE OF THE LANGUAGE AS NOT
ENTITLING THEIR DISABILITY
DISABLED RETIRED PEACE OFFICERS
TO QUALIFY FOR A CCW THIS THIS
BILL SIMPLY CORRECTS THAT.
TECHNICAL DIFFERENCE AND PUTS
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS WHO ALSO PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE IN THE
SAME CATEGORY AS EVERY OTHER
PIECE OFFICER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO RETIRES BY
SERVICE OR BY.
REASON OF DISABILITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER MONEY CENTER
MINING.
CENTER ROCKY MAKE CLOTHES WELL
THANK YOU.
I HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FOR SANTA BARBARA BUT
I WOULD NOTE.
THAT THE COSCO.
AND THE INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN
THAT SHOOTING.
ARE IN MY DISTRICT.
THEY ARE MY CONSTITUENTS SO I'M
ACUTELY AWARE OF THE SITUATION
THAT OCCURRED RIGHT DOWN THE
ROAD AT THAT COSCO.
ON THAT PARTICULAR DAY.
SECOND I WOULD NOTE THAT IS A AS
ATTORNEYS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRAINED -- TO
SEEK OUT THE FACTS AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THEM BEFORE WE
EXPRESS OPINIONS OR DRAW
CONCLUSIONS.
AND THE LAST TIME I CHECKED.
WITH REGARD TO THAT SITUATION
THAT TRAGEDY AT THAT COSCO.
THE REPORT OF INVESTIGATION HAS
NOT ISSUED.
WE DO NOT KNOW THE CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH THAT PEACE OFFICER
DREW HIS WEAPON.
AND WHAT AND FIRED WHETHER HE
WAS FORCED TO FIRE.
OR NOT THE ONE THING WE DO KNOW
IS THAT PEACE OFFICER WAS
HOLDING.
HIS YOUNG CHILD.
HIS YOUNG SON.
AT THE TIME.
SO AS I SAID THIS IS SIMPLY A
BILL TO CORRECT CORRECT THE
TECHNICAL DEFICIENCY TO PUT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ON PAR WITH EVERY OTHER
PIECE OFFICER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN THEY RETIRE BY VIRTUE OF
SERVICE?
OR BY VIRTUE OF DISABILITY AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH AND WITH
THAT MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED.
I BRADFORD.
CARRY OUT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
I DODD.
ARE THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
NO GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
HILL.
BY WITH SO.
I OUR TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
NOTE JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MOORLACH [inaudible]
I'M REAL.
HI NIELSEN PAN.
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
THE PILOT COUNTY.
WIENER.
AYE WILK.
BY.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT OR CONFUSED MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GROVE NOTIFY [inaudible]
ATKINS BRADFORD [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
THE MORNING.
NIELSEN PAN SKINNER [inaudible]
WHAT CASKEY?
ICE THIRTY KNOWS TO MEASURE
PASSES.
AND I WOULD SAY I'VE DONE THAT
MORE THAN ONCE SO.
I SHOULD NOT THROW STONES A
GLASS HOUSES MOVING MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
WHAT'S THE LEGAL TWELVE NINETY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER POWER CON
AND ACCOLADE FARMS.
CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT OF MADAME
PRESIDENT.
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS --
IT'S NOT THAT FUNNY.
SOME MAY SAY.
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM NORTH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
TODAY I PRESENT -- AB TWELVE
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER QUE HAN WHICH WOULD UPDATE
THE PROCEDURE FOR TAKING OF
POSSESSION OF GUNS FOR WHAT IS
KNOWN AS AN OPERATION OF LAW
PROCEDURE.
OPERATION OF LAW WAS CREATED IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO IN ORDER TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS PROPERLY TAKE
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM TO IN A
STATE TRUST THE CONSERVATORSHIP.
WITHOUT HAVING A GUN DEALER
INVOLVED WHICH CAN BE VERY
PROBLEMATIC IN THESE SITUATIONS.
UNDER THIS PROCEDURE PEOPLE CAN
TAKE POSSESSION OF GUNS WITHOUT
DEALER INVOLVEMENT BUT MUCH
REGISTER THAT GUN.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OBTAIN A FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATE AND UNDERGO THE
TYPICAL BACKGROUND CHECK.
THE DISPOSITION OF THE GUN BY
THAT PERSON IS SUBJECT TO THE
NORMAL -- THROUGH DEALER PRO
PROCESSING RULES.
FROM THE NEARLY THIRTY YEARS
SINCE OPERATION Là.
OPERATION OF LAW WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW WE HAVE NOT UPDATED THE
STATUE TO REFLECT OUR OTHER
UPDATED LAWS PERTAINING TO
FIREARMS.
AB TWELVE NINETY TWO EXPANDS AND
CLARIFIES THE LIST OF WHAT IS AN
OPERATION OF LAW TRANSACTION THE
COVER SITUATIONS THAT DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE CONSIDERS.
OPERATION OF LAW TRANSACTIONS
NOW TO INCLUDE CONSERVATORSHIP
SPECIAL ADMINISTRATORS POWER OF
ATTORNEY SITUATIONS.
WHICH I IN A SUB CATEGORY OF
CASES INVOLVES.
ABSENT FORSMAN TRUSTEE OF TRUST
GUARDIANS IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS
BY CLARIFYING AND UPDATING THE
LIST WE ARE MAKING SURE GOOD
ACTORS ARE NOT PENALIZED.
DUE TO OUT OF DATE LAWS THE BILL
BILL ALSO HELPS -- THE COURTS
BECAUSE THERE IS A REFERENCE TO
POWER OF ATTORNEY I IN STATUTE
BUT THE RELINQUISHMENT POLICE
PROCEDURES ARE NOT CLEAR.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT BY
UPDATING THE POWER OF ATTORNEY
PROCEDURES -- IT'S GOING TO HELP
ON SIGNIFICA REDUCING
SIGNIFICANT VOLUMES MAKING CLEAR
THAT OPERATION OF LAW PROCEDURES.
ARE IN FACT APPLY TO ALL POWER
OF ATTORNEY SITUATIONS MAY MEAN --
MORE CONSERVE RELINQUISH FOR THE
COURTS THUS REDUCING BACKLOGS
THIS WAS NOTED IN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS PER THE
BILL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE A BETTER IDEA.
OF WHO WOULD RELINQUISH WHAT
GUIDANCE TO WHOM THIS BILL HAS
HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I DON'T
THINK IT'S HAD ANY NO VOTES AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
FROM MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE FROM
NORTH LOS ANGELES COUNTY THANK
YOU CENTER PORTANTINO ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY SEVEN TWO ZERO NOW MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE
SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
NATURALLY INTO THE FAIRFIELD
SYSOON SEWER DISTRICT AND KIND
THERE'S THREATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER PRESIDENT IN MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT AB FIVE THIRTY
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT
YOUR CURRY.
AB FIVE THIRTY ALLOWS THE
FAIRFIELD TO SOON SEWER DISTRICT
TO EXTEND THEIR SERVICES TO
MIDDLE GREEN VALLEY.
IF APPROVED BILL GREEN VALLEY IS
AN UNINCORPORATED CITY JUST
OUTSIDE -- BUT AT A CORPORATE
COUNTY IN THE ANY CORPORATE
COUNTY JUST OUTSIDE THE CITIES
OF FAIRFIELD TOO SOON -- IN
ORDER FOR THE SEWER DISTRICT TO
SERVICE THESE NEW HOMES THEY
MUST.
MAKE CHANGES TO THEIR ENABLING
ACT THE A LEGISLATION AB FIVE
THIRTY A LOCAL BILL DOES JUST
THAT.
THIS BILL AS ZERO NO VOTES AND
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE.
SEEING NNE THIS IS A CANDID FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE ON THE URGENCY
THIRTY SEVEN TO ZERO IN ON THE
BILL AND SHE THIRTY SEVEN TO
ZERO MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL FILE
ITEM OF THE DAY.
NUMBER.
EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR MCGUIRE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACKLEY LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR CENTER MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
ARE RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
SIXTY TWO AND WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU.
TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN IS SUING
AGUIAR-CURRY FOR WORK ON THIS.
SB SIX THREE TWO ALLOWS THE
COUNTY OF LAKE TO COSOLIDATE
THE ELECTED OFFICES ARE
CONTROLLER IN THE TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR. FIVE OTHER COUNTIES
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY DONE SO
LAKE COUNTY HAS BEEN DEVASTATED
AS YOU ALL KNOW BY WILDFIRES
YEAR AFTER YEAR IN FACT OVER 60%
OF THE LAND MASS IS BURNED.
IN FACES FINANCIAL CHALLENGES AS
A RESULT AS PART OF THEIR FISCAL
CRISIS MANAGEMENT PLAN COUNTY
OFFICIALS PROPOSE COMBINE THESE
TWO THIS CALL OFFICES TO CUT
DOWN ON COUNTY COSTS BUT STILL
SERVICE OUR CONSTITUENTS WITH
FANTASTIC.
WORK SB SIX THIRTY TWO GIVES
LAKE COUNTY A TOOL TO HELP THEM
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET IN THE
THIRTY TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS ISSUE.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR MCGUIRE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES.
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MERRELL [inaudible]
HI.
NIELSEN PAN.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROSS [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE OUR COUNTY.
I WIENER AYE WILK BY.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBER ATKINS.
GORGEOUS.
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN PAN.
HIGHS THIRTY SIX KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW WILL RETURN
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
THIS IS APPROPRIATE TIME. TO
ADDRESS A TURNING MEMORIES.
A BEFORE WE PROCEED TO THAT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JUNE TWENTY FOURTH
THROUGH THE TWENTY SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
WITH THAT SENATOR BREAUX.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
KNOW THESE ADJOURNMENT REASER A
LITTLE LATE BUT WE'VE BEEN BUSY
ON THE FLOOR SO I DIDN'T WANT TO
TAKE UP ANY MORE TIME THEN WE
HAD.
TO BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
MISTER PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
THAT I HONOR THE MEMORY OF A LIE
IS CHECK CAT AT MR HAD IT IS AN
ICON IN KERN COUNTY AND IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN HE
BECOMES A TO AUTO.
SALES AND AUTO DEALERSHIPS AS AN
IMMIGRANT FROM LEBANON.
THE TICKET THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT.
AS AN IMMIGRANT FROM LEBANON
MISTER HAD CAME TO AMERICA TO
CITY ENGINEERING.
AND HE HAD A FEW DOLLARS STONE
IN HIS POCKET BECAUSE HIS MOM
THAT HE WOULD LOSE IT AND A CUTE
LITTLE PINK SUITCASE.
NOW I KEEP ADDRESSING HIM AS MR
HAD AT HE WAS ALLIES CHECKOUT AT
A LOT OF PEOPLE CALLED HIM CHECK.
BUT I COULD NEVER DO THAT
BECAUSE WITH MISTER HADAD
CHIVALRY WAS NEVER DEAD HE HAD A
QUIET AUTHORITATIVE KINDA
FATHERLY WAY ABOUT HIM.
AND IN THE LAST PART OF HIS LIFE
HE ENDED UP HAVING TO LIVE WITH
HIS SON AND HE WAS REALLY UPSET
ABOUT GIVING UP IS INDEPENDENCE
BUT EVERYWHERE.
THEY WOULD GO HE WOULD GO TO AND
THEY WERE THE THREE MESQUITEERS.
SO JOHN AND MEREDITH WERE
SITTING AT MARIE CALLENDER'S ONE
DAY.
AND MR HAD WAS WITH THEM AND I
WALKED IN AND SAW HIM AND WE
VISITED FOR A FEW MINUTES AND WE
WENT BACK TO OUR TABLES.
AND AT THE END I CALLED THE
WAITRESS OVER AND I SAID I'D
LIKE TO BUY THEIR MEAL.
JUST BECAUSE IT WAS A JUST A
BREAKFAST IT WAS AND IT WAS JUST
A GESTURE A NICE GESTURE SO I
SAID I'D LIKE TO BUY THEIR MEAL.
AND WHEN THOSE WITH A SERVER
CAME BACK TO ME AND I WROTE THE
CHECK MISTER HAD CAME OVER TO ME.
AND VERY STERNLY HE LOOKED OUT I
MEAN HE SAID.
A MAN NEVER ALLOWS A WOMAN TO
BUY HIS MEAL.
HE NEVER ALLOWS A WOMAN TO OPEN
THE DOOR.
WE ALWAYS MAKE SURE WE OPEN THE
DOOR FOR THE LADIES HE WAS VERY
VERY VERY CHEVROLET US AND I
KNOW THAT.
THAT THAT DEMEANOR AND THINGS
HAVE CHANGED WITH ALL THE STUFF
THAT'S GOING ON IN THE WORLD
TODAY ABOUT WOMEN BUT I JUST
THINK THAT THAT HONOR THAT HE
SHOWED WOMEN I THOUGHT WAS
PRETTY PHENOMENAL AND I DEEPLY
RESPECT HIM FOR THAT.
HE STARTED AT SCHOOL BACK EAST
BUT HE QUICKLY MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE WEATHER
WAS MUCH NICER.
AS A STUDENT STAMPER HE WALKED
ON AT A CAR DEALERSHIP IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN TO BUY HIS
FIRST CAR IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
AND BECAUSE OF HIS GOOD
NEGOTIATING SKILLS THEY
IMMEDIATELY OFFERED HIM A JOB.
FOLLOWING THAT FATEFUL DAY
MISTER HAD OPENED HIS OWN
DEALERSHIP IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
AND LATER OPEN THE BAKERSFIELD
AUTO DEALERSHIP KNOWN AS HAD
AUTOMOTIVE GROUP.
MR HAD AND WAS RECOGNIZED FOR
HIS FAN -- CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE STATE
REGARDING AUTO DEALERSHIPS IN
HIS CIVIC SERVICE HIS LEGACY --
LIVES THROUGHOUT EVERY PART OF
HIS LIFE MR HAD IT IS PRECEDED
IN DEATH BY HIS BEAUTIFUL WIFE
YOUNGER.
AND HIS SON JEFF EN GOING TO
JEFF'S FUNERAL WHO IS ALSO VERY
MUCH INVOLVED IN THE CAR
DEALERSHIP ASSOCIATION THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN SACRAMENTO -- WAS
PRETTY DEVASTATING ON MR HAD ADD
AND SO NOW -- AT THE FUNERAL
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
SPOKE ABOUT HOW HE WOULD JOIN
AND ANGER AND HIS SON JEFF AND
HAVEN'T SO I WOULD JUST ASK FOR
THIS MAN'S LEGACY.
IN THE CAR DEALERSHIP
ASSOCIATION AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT HE SERVED THAT WE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE AND
HAVING KNOWN THEY HAD IT SET
FAMILY KNOW WHAT A DEVASTATING
THE LOSS THAT IS TO THE
RESIDENTS OF KERN COUNTY.
THANK YOU.
ARE YOU AVE ANOTHER JOURNEY
MEMORY I DO AND I WOULD RECEIVE
COLLEAGUES YEAH I WOULD REMIND
THE THE BODY TO SHOW DEFERENCE
AND KEEP THE NOISE DOWN PLEASE
PROCEED.
AND I I DO -- IT ASKED MY
COLLEGE AND COLLEAGUES
INDULGENCE BECAUSE WE WE DID
WAIT ON THESE RESOLUTIONS AND SO
I APPLY I APPRECIATE YOU LETTING
ME DO THEM TODAY.
I RISE AGAIN INJURING A MEMORY
OF THE LEGENDARY ENTREPRENEUR IN
KERN COUNTY FRED STAR.
FRED STAR WAS INCREDIBLE CENTRAL
VALLEY FARMERS WHO WAS
ORIGINALLY FROM ARIZONA HE GREW
HIS FAMILY FARM FROM THIRTY FIVE
ACRES. TO SEVERAL THOUSAND ACRES
AND EXPANDING HIS PRODUCTION
FROM COTTON AND ALFALFA TO
ALMONDS AND PISTACHIOS.
DURING A SIXTY EIGHT YEAR
FARMING CAREER HE WAS HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN NATIONAL AND LOCAL
COTTON INDUSTRY AND WAS ALSO
INVOLVED IN LOCAL AGRICULTURAL.
AND WATER DISTRICTS AND CO OPS
FRED SERVED A VARIETY CAPACITIES --
DURING HIS TIME ADVOCATING FOR
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY HE
SERVED AS THE ADVISER THE
NATIONAL COTTON COUNCIL DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
COALITION -- FOUNDING PRESIDENT
OF FARMERS COOPERATIVE IN ALMOND
HOLLER DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION PRESIDENT
OF OF THE CALIFORNIA COTTON
GROWERS AND THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON AND O HE WAS APPOINTED TO
SERVE ON THE COTTON AGRICULTURAL
TRADE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AND COTTON MARKETING COMMITTEE
BY THE SECRETARY OF AGRICULTURE
I DURING THE GEORGE H. W. BUSH
ADMINISTRATION ADVISE THE TEAM.
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
NINETEEN NINETY FARM BILL HE WAS
MORE THAN JUST A FARMER HE WAS A
COMMUNITY OF A COMMUNITY.
CONTRIBUTORS FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS
ON THE BOARD OF THE KERN HIGH
SCHOOL TRUSTEE DISTRICT BOARD HE
WAS ALSO -- WITH THE REGIONAL
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT HE'S A
FOUNDING MEMBER THE SHAFT ARREST
RECREATION DISTRICT WHICH AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL AUDITORIUM BECAUSE
ITS FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTIONS IS
NAMED AFTER HIM -- HIM HE'S IN
THE INCORPORATED COTTON
INCORPORATED INDUSTRIES HALL OF
FAME NATIONALLY.
HE LOST THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE FOR
FIFTY FOUR YEARS NANCY AND THE
KIDS REALLY THOUGHT THAT HE
WASN'T GONNA MAKE IT THEM HE
STARTED SLEEPING ON THEIR COUCH
HE REALLY STRUGGLED WITH --
WAKING UP EVEN IN THE MORNING
AFTER THE LOSS OF HIS WIFE OF
FOR CANCER.
IN THE KIDS NOTICED A COUPLE
YEARS LATER HE HAD A PEP IN A
STEP.
AND HE MET A LOVELY LADY NAME
LINDA AND THE FUNERAL WAS REALLY
AMAZING HOW THEY HONOR BOTH
WOMEN'S LIFE IN CONTROL
CONTRIBUTION TO THEIR FATHER.
AS THE MOTHER OF HIS CHILDREN
OBVIOUSLY FOR FIFTY FOUR YEARS
AND THEN THE WOMAN THAT GAVE HIS
FAMILY ANOTHER ELEVEN YEARS OF
LIFE SO THAT THEY COULD
CELEBRATE THAT WITH HIM.
HE LOVED MUSIC AND HIS FAMILY
ALWAYS WAS REQUIRED TO SING AT
ALL EVENTS AND ALL OF HIS
CHILDREN ARE VERY MUSICAL I KNOW
THAT HE IS DEEPLY MISSED BY HIS
FAMILY.
AND WE LOST TWO AMAZING ICONS IN
KERN COUNTY SO I ASK YOU TO TURN
IN THEIR MEMORY.
THANK YOU THAT CENTER GROVE.
ANY OTHER JOURNEY MEMORIES.
SAYING THAT IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
DESK IS CLEAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL FIVE PM AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE PLACED WE
WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT TWO
PM.
HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND.
AS ALREADY NOTED THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL FIVE PM AT
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE PLACED WE'LL RECONVENE
BACK HERE MONDAY AT TWO PM.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND MEMBERS